opposers we all know who the most
persecuted group in America is that's
right men did you know a whopping five
percent of US companies have female CEOs
which means that with the exception of
ninety five percent of the economy women
control the economy this all points to
one thing
wardrobe lady there's a war on men
something ominous is happening to men in
America a war on men
food that's right men there's a war on
us and not even the spurious - bone
spurs will get us out of it
you see women have decided were the bad
guys just because we're reluctant to
change a system that benefits us at
their expense and now they're hitting us
below the belt and slightly to the side
and no get your head out of the gutter
I'm talking about our wallets
battleground one money yes you know that
fake pay gap women keep complaining
about well I believe in it now because
it's hurting men there are now seven
places in the US where women earn more
than men seven places but I say even one
is too many did you know that every time
a woman out earns a man an angel loses
his erection and then punches a wall
it's true and now these greedy women
don't just want to take our money they
want to be our money
check it a new bipartisan bill to put
more women on US coins their portraits
would appear on the backside of the
coins opposite George Washington the
first design mock-ups could arrive in
2020 the 100th anniversary of women
gaining the right to vote how
appropriate
no more like non appropriate I can't
make heads or tails of this oh oh I'm
sorry I mean heads or lady heads of this
feel gross and oppressive that feels
this is a huge problem and not just
because for girl quarters will only be
worth 79 cents
it's clear the female vagenda is trying
to use small change to change the world
as we know it
so no tubby relax man it's just a coin
no no representation matters okay first
it's our quarters then our dollars and
then young girls start seeing themselves
represented everywhere and pretty soon I
have to explain to my son truck that he
can't grow up to be whatever he wants
because they put a lady at a quarter and
now there's a more qualified woman out
there who also wants to be a ninja
astronauts so you better learn to cook a
goddamn egg it's just not fair what yes
yes look women aren't just coming for
our moolah they're also coming for our
manhood which brings me to battleground
two penises look what they're doing with
our penises actresses Kate Blanchet and
Sandra Bullock they are both gorgeous
women yes flawless skin yes they have
tried these so called this is an
anatomical reference the so called
penis facial wait it happens to be
derived from the foreskin of Korean
newborns oh my goodness
a hard-hitting report from what I could
only assume is an everyday episode of
good morning Belfast this is outrageous
these penis facials go against the
natural order I'll say it loud and proud
penises are only for men to enjoy but
now women are using our dicks to trick
us into thinking they're prettier that
they are that is vain
women what have men ever done to make
you think your value is based on your
physical appearance this is clearly a
diabolical plot to steal our male
essence our power our influence our
ability to grill meat outdoors and don't
tell me relax man it's just the tip
[Applause]
that's how it starts
first it's the foreskin facial that it's
the testicle earrings and before you
know it some witchy woman is wearing
your skin doing your job and woman
spreading all over the bus while
screaming at you to smile more don't
want to smile you've taken my skin and
my job and it sucks final battleground
physical strength look maybe you're a
tough guy maybe you think women are weak
well think again the northeastern ladies
basketball team was on the way to what a
game a big game and something horrible
happened their bus got stuck so you know
what they did they did what women do
and they started pushing maastrichtian
out the power of estrogen what is that
the tagline for Wonder Woman to Kamala
Harris is 2020 campaign slogan a
little-known b-side from Huey Lewis in
the news that's the power of estrogen
what is it but the power the power of
estrogen is scary the out of me and not
just because I once read that eating
edamame will give you moobs no this is
America men are supposed to be the
strong ones
have you seen me open a jar trick
question if you'd seen me we'd already
be dating these women they are stealing
my thunder
oh don't tell me relax man it's just an
inspiring story about a women's
basketball team no this is the beginning
of the end these women are saying hey
men we don't need you anymore instead of
waiting for some streetwise Hercules to
bail them out they bolt rond into one
big her Chili's
and she's scaring the enemy so men
let this be a call to you to join the
resistance men we must stand up and
defend ourselves we must be defensive
health will be overly defensive equality
is a finite resource and women are on a
shopping spree to gobble it all up so we
need to protect what little we have left
which is going to be tough because it's
still almost everything it's so hard
stay strong men the fight continues